[Musica]
è possibile descrivere l'andamento di
una vita tramite un modello economico
Secondo me sì e oggi cercherò di
spiegarvi brevemente perché partiamo
dall'inizio cerchiamo di capire come
funzioniamo se io chiedessi a ognuno di
voi come stai Quindi Pensateci come stai
probabilmente molti di voi mi direbbero
è un periodo che va un po' così non sto
benissimo altri mi direbbero un periodo
fantastico va Tutto bene Va bene tutto
poi sono chiaramente casi estremi casi
nella media però tendenzialmente quando
rispondiamo a questo tipo di domanda
quello quello che facciamo
inconsciamente in modo più o meno
consapevole è paragonare il modo in cui
siamo rispetto a quello degli altri
Quindi ci paragoniamo con gli altri che
sono amici colleghi conoscenti con altre
persone o paragoniamo noi stessi
rispetto al nostro passato quindi stiamo
meglio o peggio rispetto a come ci
sentivamo prima quindi qui c'è il primo
biio per capire come sto e come posso
stare potenzialmente meglio devo
confrontarmi con gli altri o con il
passato partiamo dagli altri
sin da quando siamo bambini Iniziamo a
pensare diciamo siamo indotti
inconsciamente a pensare tramite
confronti tramite paragoni quando
torniamo da scuola dopo aver fatto una
verifica e diciamo i nostri genitori ho
preso sette i nostri genitori ci diranno
Qualcuno ha preso 9 10 Sì E perché non
l'hai preso tu quindi Lì c'è il primo
confronto Allora tu dici ok Non ho preso
il massimo ma non ho preso neanche il
minimo C sono tanti altri che hanno
preso due tre qu perché io devo puntare
ancora più in alto quindi in amente da
quando siamo piccoli continuiamo a
paragonarci rispetto agli altri per
capire qual è il nostro valore ma in
realtà più andiamo avanti nella vita più
diventiamo consapevoli più capiamo che
in realtà questo lo dicono tanti studi
psicologici che non citerò che
paragonarsi agli altri per sentirsi
meglio è pura follia È completamente
inutile semplicemente perché siamo tutte
persone diverse con ritmi diversi
percorsi diversi priorità diverse e
obiettivi diversi quindi pensare di
stare meglio o rispetto agli altri
appunto paragonando con gli altri
diventa semplicemente un mezzo per
sentirci frustrati perciò paragonarsi
con gli altri non è sicuramente una
buona idea A meno che non vogliamo
vivere frustrati se ci piace quello è un
altro discorso Quindi facciamo un passo
indietro torniamo indietro nel bivio
infatti Molto probabilmente vi sarà
capitato di scorrere sui social uno di
quei post motivazionali in cui viene
detto non devi paragonarti con gli altri
Devi paragonarti con il tè del passato
devi migliorare rispetto al tè del
passato quindi andiamo un po' più a
fondo a questa a questa frase andiamo a
vedere cosa c'è nel passato se noi
diciamo di dover essere migliori
rispetto al passato stiamo
implicitamente assumendo che il me di
oggi è funzione del me di ieri quindi io
dipendo da quello che ero ieri più
qualcosa che capita degli eventi più o
meno casuali che ci capitano Tutti i
giorni che appunto ci rendono un giorno
migliore dell'altro un giorno peggiore
Ma questi sono eventi puramente diciamo
per la maggior parte imprevedibili
quindi senza andare a citare filosofi
stoici Diciamo che sono fuori dal nostro
controllo e quindi non dovremmo troppo
preoccuparci di quello che ci capita
dovremmo preoccuparci del modo in cui
rispondiamo a quello che ci capita
Guardate ora questi due grafici Eh sono
due serie temporali quindi sull'asse
orizzontale c'è il tempo sull'asse
verticale c'è quello che volete Quindi
potete vederlo come una serie di prezzi
una serie di rendimenti l'inflazione
qualsiasi cosa io la vedo e la cercherò
di di raccontare come l'andamento di una
vita se vi chiedono disegnate il grafico
della vostra vita io posso disegnarlo in
questo modo è oggettivo dire che questi
due grafici sono diametralmente opposti
quindi uno sempre decrescente uno è
sempre crescente ma in realtà questi due
grafici derivano esattamente dallo
stesso processo hanno una cosa in comune
Sono esattamente due processi
autoregressive si chiamano derivano
esattamente da questa formula che è
quella che ci siamo appena detti cioè il
me di oggi è pare al me di ieri più una
cosa che capita in modo casuale Questo è
il modello autor regressivo che può
portare a quelle due direzioni ma
altrettante infinite e imprevedibili
direzioni quindi questo è un modello che
noi applichiamo che per definizione è
imprevedibile si chiama anche Random
Walk camminata aleatoria camminata
casuale immaginatelo come una persona
che esce totalmente ubriaca da un bar e
non sa esattamente dove andare quindi
ogni passo che fa è legato al Passo di
prima ma essendo ubriaca va un po'
zigzag quindi può finire con la stessa
stessa probabilità lontanissimo rispetto
a dove vuole andare con la stessa
probabilità Nella direzione opposta o
con la stessa probabilità arriva
esattamente dove voleva
arrivare questo tipo di
processi hanno una caratteristica
fondamentale Cioè sono legati al passato
sono molto pesanti ci portiamo con noi
tutto il peso delle scelte passate e vi
assicuro che se facessimo questo per 100
passi per 100 giorni arriveremo a questo
Cioè che il me dopo 100 giorni è pari al
me iniziale quindi il me senza nessun
bagaglio più tutte le scelte che ho
fatto tutte le cose che mi sono capitate
tutti i modi in cui ho deciso di
rispondere alle cose che sono successe
quindi è come se io portassi con me una
valigia sempre più grossa che
inizialmente controllo benissimo ma poi
inizia a diventare molto grande ed è lei
a controllare me non riesco più a dare
un indirizzo alla mia vita se dipendo
troppo dal
passato quindi questo grafico si può
vedere in questo modo almeno io lo
interpreto in questo modo perciò Questa
può essere vista tranquillamente come la
prima fase della nostra nostra vita in
cui siamo molto inconsapevoli quindi
facciamo le cose perché vanno così
Quindi non abbiamo una direzione esatta
andiamo Rispetto a dove eravamo prima ci
mettiamo un più Meno uno e
camminiamo In realtà nella vita poi con
questo approccio inconsapevole o si va a
sbattere o comunque bisogna dare una
direzione bisogna prendere delle scelte
importanti Quindi bisogna dare una
direzione una volta che si apprende
dagli errori fatti in passato si può
decidere di metterci qualcosa in più
Appunto e dare una direzione sempre
essendo legate al passato cioè se io
voglio migliorare posso cambiare le mie
attitudini i miei comportamenti le mie
percezioni rispetto a tutto questo che
ho fatto e quindi essere una persona più
determinata cercare di metterci più
impegno in quello che faccio e quindi
mettere insieme a tutto questo un + un
ogni giorno facendo così otteniamo
questa equazione molto semplificata di
un processo autor regressivo si dice con
Drift Quindi con una direzione ci
mettiamo un più uno semplicemente Ogni
giorno che passa questa dinamica che
dipende sempre dal passato ci porterà
nel tempo a una crescita quindi c'è
variazione nel tempo ma intorno a un
trend positivo Quindi si può crescere Ma
la crescita anche qui può essere un'arma
a doppio taglio perché se è vero che per
impegnarci per metterci quel più un
quotidianamente abbiamo bisogno di
vedere che ha senso quello che facciamo
quindi dobbiamo girarci indietro e dire
Ok mi impegno più un sto meglio rispetto
a prima faccio un sacrificio in più
Voglio guardarmi indietro per vedere che
sto migliorando ma dopo un' in quanto
esseri umani
ottimizzano al miglioramento non diamo
diamo tutto per scontato quindi
cercheremo sempre di voler crescere di
più e di non accontentarci mai e dato
che è difficile mantenere una
sostenibilità in termini di crescita
appunto di ritmo a cui stiamo crescendo
arriverà a un punto in cui questo mi
ricorda molto Sisifo della mitologia
greca che è costretto per l'eternità a
portare un masso pesantissimo verso la
cima di un monte da Zeus e quindi anche
che dopo quando scende lui lo deve
riprendere lo deve riportare sempre
verso la cima quindi essere ossessionati
dalla performance e dal miglioramento
può portare semplicemente a dipendere
dal passato e a non essere più in grado
di sostenere tutto quello che abbiamo
fatto quindi arriverà un punto in cui
questo peso sarà troppo grande da
gestire e quindi dobbiamo in qualche
modo lasciarlo andare e quindi l'unico
modo per non arrivare né all'equilibrio
di prima né a questo è lasciare andare
un po' il passato e questo è descritto
tramite processi a media mobile si
chiamano che come potete vedere non ho
inserito l'equazione perché sarebbe
stata un po' complicata però vi assicuro
che la dinamica di tutte le simulazioni
di questo modello è questa quindi c'è
una media alla quale si tende e c'è una
variabilità quotidiana Ma questo
processo rispetto a quelli precedenti
Dipende solo in minima parte dal passato
quindi ci sleghiamo dal passato e siamo
in qualche modo molto più leggeri non
abbiamo più una valigia pesante con
tutti i ricordi con tutte le scelte che
abbiamo fatto che influenzano il modo in
cui noi osserviamo la realtà ma andiamo
Come direbbe Romagnoli solo bagaglio a
mano quindi andiamo molto leggeri una
vita completamente diversa quindi questo
mi
ricorda se lo vedessimo come delle onde
in un mare mi ricorda un po' la frase
del filosofo stoico Seneca che dice
Nessun vento è favorevole per il
marinaio che non sa In quale porto
approdare che non sa In quale direzione
andare quindi piuttosto che focalizzarci
su un obiettivo Se non ce l'abbiamo in
una certa fase della nostra vita
focalizziamoci sul costruire una barca
che ci Renda imperturbabili rispetto a
tutte le correnti che possono arrivare
oppure Vediamola come questo che Naviga
con il surf Cioè dobbiamo essere leggeri
dobbiamo imparare a rimanere in
equilibrio rispetto a tutto quello che
ci Capita nella vita ma essendo slegati
dal passato in modo tale da essere più
leggeri e rimanere intorno alla nostra
identità intorno a una
media mettendo insieme questi tre
grafici possono essere visti
tranquillamente come tre diversi
approcci alla vita tre persone diverse o
come tre fasi di una propria vita ma
anche come tre fasi di qualsiasi
processo temporale può essere visto
anche nel mondo degli investimenti cioè
io nella prima fase non so bene come
funziona il mercato quindi magari in
modo più o meno casuale mi può andare
benissimo mi può andare malissimo vado a
sbattere e quindi da lì in poi inizio a
utilizzare una strategia un po' più
cauta con cautela quindi abbasso un po'
il mio ritorno ma abbasso anche il mio
rischio Quindi metto da parte volta per
volta reinvesto i soldi che guadagno
tramite la capitalizzazione l'interesse
composto e nel lungo periodo avrò un
capitale che cresce in media
chiaramente quando arrivo a un
determinato capitale posso anche essermi
stancato di volere sempre un rendimento
maggiore e quindi posso anche
tranquillamente decidere di voler
preservare il capitale quindi non
necessariamente crescere sempre di più
l'ossessione per la crescita quindi
quando vi capita qualsiasi evento
Provate a immaginare in Quale di questi
tre Vi rispecchiate cioè come rispondete
agli eventi che capitano date tanto al
passato in modo inconsapevole o lo state
facendo perché siete in una fase di
crescita oppure siete già qui e avete
questa capacità di slegar VII più o meno
dal passato di vedere le cose che vi
arrivano e valutarle in base a un peso
diverso quindi non dipendere dall'errore
o dall'evento ma essere parte
dell'evento che è una cosa completamente
diversa Ora voglio farvi un'altra
domanda Chi non vorrebbe avere una mente
perfetta una memoria perfetta che si
ricordi di
tutto nessuno ha voglio alzare le mani
quindi va bene lo stesso però
probabilmente a tutti piacerebbe avere
una mente perfetta alcuni vedo che
dicono di no però al più del 90%
Probabilmente
sì ricordare perfettamente qui Cito uno
scritto di Borg che è un autore
argentino che parla di un soggetto Funes
che aveva una memoria perfetta ricordava
perfettamente tutto quello che ha visto
provato sentito pensato in passato ed è
arrivato al punto in cui Deve vivere
chiuso da solo in una stanza buia cupa e
umida perché non può avere più input
all'esterno perché deve passare il tempo
a ricordare tutto a Codificare tutto
quello che ha avuto tutto quello che ha
passato tanto che finiscono le parole e
deve iniziare a utilizzare dei codici
dei numeri perché sono potenzialmente
limitate le combinazioni di numeri per
appunto per ricordarsi tutte le nuove
cose quindi essere ancorati al passato
ci priva della possibilità di capire
Appunto quello che succede Adesso di
vederlo con occhi differenti in modo più
oggettivo in realtà il nostro cervello
funziona un po' così funziona con il
modello più semplice perché il nostro
cervello è sempre in modalità risparmio
energetico non gli piace sforzarsi
Quindi quando capita un evento e
dobbiamo scegliere o non scegliere la
cosa che viene molto facile al nostro
cervello è dire ok le cose sono andate
sempre così quindi mi faccio una
proiezione rispetto al primo modello che
abbiamo visto quindi quello più facile
dice Ok sto qui perché sono arrivato qui
provo a fare la cosa che mi fa spostare
meno di tutte le
altre e quindi questo ci porta
Paradossalmente all'inazione alla non
scelta la non scelta diventa
paradossalmente la scelta perché appunto
il nostro cervello Cerca rispetto a
quello che ha preso dal passato di fare
cose che diano meno sforzo possibile
applica il modello previsionale più
semplice che esista che è il primo che
abbiamo visto quindi saper dimenticare o
meglio avere la capacità di lasciare
andare un po' il peso del passato è una
grande qualità una grande arte è
sinonimo anche di intelligenza e ci fa
vivere in modo molto migliore di
miglioramento anche qui ci tengo a
precisare miglioramento in cosa e
rispetto a cosa perché molto spesso noi
diciamo che voglio migliorare nel lavoro
ma migliorare in qualcosa non significa
essere delle persone migliori che è
esattamente un'altra cosa Quindi
pensiamoci quando noi andiamo in
palestra Io sono il primo che ci va e ci
alleniamo lo facciamo perché vogliamo
dimostrare agli altri quando andiamo al
mare in spiaggia che abbiamo un fisico
perfetto e quindi ci confrontiamo con
gli altri per stare meglio noi stessi o
lo facciamo per vedere quali sono i
nostri limiti fino a dove posso
spingermi quando andiamo a correre una
maratona lo facciamo perché vogliamo
capire se la nostra essenza la troviamo
al nostro limite oppure perché vogliamo
scappare da casa dai problemi che
abbiamo non vogliamo parlare con nostra
moglie con i nostri figli e quindi
migliorare in qualcosa non implica
essere persone migliori che è tutta
un'altra storia ora ci ci tenevo a a
concludere con questa frase di Cristina
murti che è un filosofo indiano che
fondamentalmente dice che migliorare
essenzialmente significa desiderare
qualcosa che non si ha o non si è e
quindi questo crea un conflitto
all'interno di noi finché non saremo
contenti con quello che abbiamo quello
che siamo saremo sempre insoddisfatti
lui dice noi facciamo sempre paragoni
tra quello che siamo e quello che
dovremmo essere quello che dovremmo
essere è semplicemente una proiezione di
quello che noi pensiamo di dover essere
e quindi qui sorge una contraddizione la
contraddizione sorge ogni qualvolta
facciamo un paragone che sia con gli
altri o che sia con noi stessi del
passato mentre la vera pace la vera
libertà è vivere con ciò che si è e ciò
che si ha Quindi se è vero che in realtà
siamo un po' la somba di tutte le scelte
fatte in passato e un po' delle persone
che abbiamo incrociato nella nostra vita
perché altrimenti non sarei qua a
parlare e non avrei un bagaglio
culturale per costruire anche questi
pensieri ma è nel nostro potere Decidere
quanto di questo debba influenzarci
quanto Essere legato legati al giudizio
altrui o al nostro passato Quindi quanto
essere in questa perenne contraddizione
che abbiamo nella nostra vita quindi
piuttosto che necessariamente migliorare
dire Diamoci l'opportunità di sbagliare
di capire di evolverci di trovare la
nostra massima essenza in qualcosa che
facciamo quindi Diamoci la
libertà di scegliere di essere quello
che siamo e di stare come stiamo non
necessariamente meglio non
necessariamente peggio stare come stiamo
essere quelli che siamo senza
necessariamente paragonarci al passato o
agli altri
grazie